well it's time to see what is making the
headlines uh of tomorrow's newspapers
with the political editor of the daily
mirror propagara and the political
editor of the sun harry cole they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight no guessing of course what's on
the front pages so let's start with the
metro a failure of leadership that's the
headline
for the paper
the financial times says boris johnson
has rejected calls to resign after the
publication of the sue gray report
the guardian finds that tory back
benchers have turned on their leader
over the 12 events being investigated by
the metropolitan police
mamma mia that's the sun's headline over
claims that an abba themed party was
held in boss johnson's downing street
flat during lockdown
while the eye has pm please for his job
the telegraph reporting that the prime
minister will ask for a new report from
sue gray in a bid to settle that anger
and remain in the top job
and here's the yorkshire post failures
of leadership in parts of number 10 the
investigation also making the front
pages in red wool areas
reminder too that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's introduce our guests
then uh tonight joined by pippacrira and
harry cole uh long awaited uh and brief
but blunted guess harry
uh yes wasn't the most exciting uh
documentary fairly damning in its uh
pithiness it was about 10 pages long but
the it's clear that the metropolitan
police's ongoing investigation which
they extraordinarily said won't take
more than a year um earlier today and
has taken a very sharp axe to that uh to
that report um it was gutted of any
uh sort of duty details you might say um
any details that could prejudice the
police investigation and was more sort
of broad brushing but it was very
withering it found
a number of uh a number of failings uh
inside number 10 inside the cabinet
office at the height of lockdown and
simply concluded um without much to that
much fuss that the rules that were
expected the rest of the country to
follow weren't followed in number 10 and
that puts the prime minister in quite an
awkward position who given the fact that
he told the house of commons that he'd
been assured and in fact he knew that
guidance had been followed at all times
so
the saga rumbles on
absolutely the guardian let's take a
look at that talks as many of the papers
do about this failure of leadership that
we heard from sue gray's report but
pippa any hope that this would be the de
numer of the work that you had started
in mid-november by first of all pointing
out the allegations of parties that were
clearly not true they're once again
shielding themselves would you say
behind both the met police and indeed
whatever else sue gray has to offer
well it is incredible how long this has
rumbled on unless harry says we're not
at the end yet i don't think anybody
really expected
once we found out that sue grave is
going to have to attract lodge was going
to have to um
turn down large parts of report and
leave big chunks out
after the police said last week that
they wanted her to
keep the details to a minimum that this
was going to be the moment that it
really came to a head for the prime
minister and we saw um in the comments
today i thought it was quite interesting
his response uh the response from the
story about benches was really angry it
seemed to go down very badly the tone
that he adopted um you had the mps led
by theresa may but many others as well
on his own benches let alone what the
opposition were up to um criticizing his
handling of the whole affair um but he
seemed to sort of pull it back a bit
when he uh got behind closed doors with
the 1922 committee and charmed his
conservative backbenchers to convince
them that now it was not the moment to
try and trigger a leadership contest i
think the timing has been the big
question like i say since last week when
the met made clear that the full report
couldn't be published um and it's gonna
be really interesting to see whether now
that the prime minister has managed to
buy some time whether he's going to be
able to press ahead and get back onto
the front foot even though we're going
to a difficult spring with cost living
crisis and then the may elections the
potential war in ukraine
or whether this is going to hang over
him and just not go away as more
revelations come out as the police
eventually gets the point where they
report back
you know they said that they have
300 pictures and 500 bits of paper
about allegations about gatherings we
learned about three new gatherings we
haven't known about up until this point
and we know that the met are looking at
at least three gatherings that the prime
minister himself was at confirming for
the first time that prime minister
potentially broke the law so it's not
going to be an easy few months for the
prime minister that they're desperate to
try and get back onto front foot
yes and it is indeed worthy of a study
of the importance of momentum in
politics is it not but let's let's go to
one of the areas harry that did irritate
conservative mps today this was the
failure of the prime minister to promise
that he would publish whatever sue grey
hector what a full report might look
like including mark harmer harper former
chief whip who had mouthed at him just
published while the pm was talking and
there the daily telegraph turning this
around suggesting the prime minister
will ask sue gray for a new report as if
it was always the plan
yeah well they were quite definitive
early on in this that when they launched
this inquiry it would be it would be
published in full and that would then be
placed in the house of commons and
everyone could chew over it then that
line has gradually softened over over
the course of weeks and
months now and then today they had a
slightly unforced error it was pretty
clear very obviously and i'm surprised
kierstarma didn't leap on it at the top
that the prime minister was very clearly
not promising to once the police
investigation had
uh concluded and published the findings
in full um now that was clearly a
lightning rod for people like mark
harper
uh in the house of commons and it took
diane abbott to be the first person to
notice it who hasn't always been on the
ball for brilliant parliamentary
questions when she was on the front
bench for example but there was a clear
feeling that actually hang on no this is
unfair we need to see if anything to put
this to bed the full details now the the
swift statement from number 10 tonight
seems to quell some of the anger they
are going to have to publish it in full
now intriguingly something i'm picking
up tonight
is the fact that the metropolitan police
haven't actually so far been running so
i haven't been publishing the names of
anyone that gets coveted um fines there
is a there is a world in which you can
see
uh a number of these fixed penalty
notices being handed out to downing
street officials downstream staff there
is a prime minister but they would never
actually be published by the met they'd
be breaking preston so another row i
think is going to be rumbling is and a
question that pepper and i will be
asking almost daily now i imagine is has
the prime minister spoken to the police
and has he been given any formal fine
because it's not on the duty it's not
the onus it's not on the police to
announce that so i expect uh those are
looking for a cries of a cover-up to
have a new angle on that one because
it's up to number 10 to say who's
actually being punished
yes pippa you said uh three of these
alleged events that the prime minister
was directly involved in i think the
times tonight is saying four
one of which there is a question mark
over is what happened on the 13th of
november which is on the front page of
the sun mamma mia that the headline
there about this alleged party in the
flat in number 10 downing street
something that the prime minister was
pointedly and and repeatedly asked about
in the commons today
yes and the prime minister when asked
about it said that he didn't want um to
uh prejudge that he didn't want to give
a running commentary while the police
investigation was going on but didn't
obviously give flat denial but he was at
the party or indeed the party took place
in his flat but this is one that we
wrote about that i wrote about back in
november number 10 and mrs johnson's
spokesman vehemently denied that
anything had taken place but i was told
that there was a gathering on night that
dominic cummings left number 10 upstairs
in the flat this is separate from the
the separate uh lee kane leaving do
downstairs that there was a small number
of people but the people got and i quote
completely plastered and that they were
blasting out loud music in subsequent
reports including some over the weekend
suggested that abbas
up as the winner takes it all was played
out in reference of course to the the
battle that was going on between carrie
johnson and her uh her friends and
allies in number 10 and dominic cummings
and his sort of vote leave campaign team
still in number 10 as well um the the
reason that this obviously despite all
this sort of you know the juicy detail
the reason that this has become
particularly relevant is because it's
the only one that we know of that the
police are investigating that actually
took part that took place in the prime
minister's own private residence so it's
very difficult in that situation for him
to turn around and give an excuse that
officials organized it or that he
thought it was a work event um it also
of course um brings in the suggestion
that his wife was involved too um number
10 as i say has completely denied that
but uh it's a very tricky one for the
prime minister and uh certainly one that
i'm sure journalists and mps are going
to be particularly interested to try and
find out more when that final su-grey
report finally publishes all those
details
yes and it's always been one of the uh
the pm's uh main defenses isn't it that
this is both his home and his office if
he's pictured with alcohol it's his home
effectively let's take a look at the
metro then harry as well another of the
newspapers that talk about a failure of
leadership one of the sentences that
really stood out in sue gray's report
but what about those changes that the
prime minister suggested uh that will
bring about uh you know a changing
culture really in downing street there
had been rumors that there might be an
outright ban on our alcohol but we
didn't hear anything about that uh one
commentator suggesting today that
instead of having the prime minister's
office we're going to get the office of
the prime minister and this won't
necessarily make much difference
yeah look number 10 does have a sort of
unique place in constitutionally in how
it's set up it's sort of evolved rather
than being as a department of its own i
think there's an interesting line in the
grey report about and i presume it's
about the prime minister's principal
private secretary martin reynolds or
party marty as he's been nicknamed um
the guy who sent the email it to the
infamous bring your own booze
event now he is meant to be the prime
minister nears his right-hand man his
civil service representative he runs his
private office he runs his day-to-day uh
organization but also he's also seen as
a figurehead in number 10 and i think
the grey person's little finger on that
as actually slightly
bizarre scenario where the most senior
civil servant apart from the cabinet
secretary who as the title dictates is
in charge of the cabinet and the running
of government and then ultimately
responsible for the civil servant number
10 is run by
essentially uh
one of the prime minister's closest
advisors and it almost has too much on
their plate there seem to be things that
are slipping through the cracks there's
a there's unclear structures around
who's actually in charge because at the
same time as having a civil servant
principal private secretary you've got
the
um chief of staff who's a political
appointee and a spad and you know who's
actually in charge
pm being pulled in different directions
this pm actually quite like playing not
against each other so all that's going
to change i think could spend the full
half hour talking about uh sugray and
downing street we move on to the other
big news today which is of course the
announcement of a consultation to uh to
ditch this idea of mandatory
vaccinations uh pippa for nhs staff
yeah this has been a little while coming
because over the last few weeks we've
heard um reels of concern from some from
hospital leaders and some of the medical
groups uh and unions suggesting that uh
the ready under pressure nhs which has
already got large units of big big
shortages and staffing could not cope
with the um sudden exit from frontline
roles of tens of thousands of nhs staff
who have yet to be vaccinated this of
course was um the decision made by the
english or by the government for the
english nhs um to
oblige frontline nhs staff in the same
way it's already happened with care
workers to get there to get there to
make sure they're fully jabbed in order
to protect patients they've said
um
there's been some speculation of the
last couple of weeks that the government
might pull back from that as a result of
those calls by those medical groups
and um
javid the health secretary
said last week that the government were
reflecting on the decision and now we've
uh as we've seen tonight uh they
announced in the commons that um they
didn't think there was any it was
proportionate anymore to given that we
sort of threw the worst of the omicron
wave
to insist that
nhs staff
get that jab because of the impact that
it could have on staffing levels so um
it's gone up to consultation and uh
we'll see what they come back with but i
think we can fully explain it but we
just
i'm gonna i'm gonna interrupt you
because we've got one minute left and
obviously we've had the breaking news
this evening that the prime minister is
planning to travel to ukraine tomorrow
uh he'll meet with the ukrainian
president harry had been due to be
accompanied too by the foreign secretary
liz trust that clearly will not happen
now she's tested positive for kovid and
in the meantime his hopes of a
conversation with president putin was
delayed the telegraph says because the
french president snuck in first you've
got about 30 seconds i apologize harry
i'm not sure it was macron uh macron uh
sneaking in first or the pm having to
spend 90 minutes um defending uh whether
or not kettle chips reached in downing
street that's the that's the big issue
with partygate is yes very serious
allegations and a lot of public anger
about rule breaking but also is sucking
so much bandwidth out of borah johnson's
time he wants to try and throw the
kitchen sink at everything this week
we've got leveling up trip to ukraine
possibly some online harms later in the
week but every time he tries to move on
he just gets dragged back in
apologies we've really run out